and your mutants are dangerous
you're not going anywhere
this place takes your greatest fear and
makes you live through it
roberto
sam diliana
danny brain
i was 13. i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i've started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend i burned her
ileana i killed 18 men one
by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
it's important we find out your caller
so we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
i don't think we're here to get better
we can get out of this together this
place is designed to keep us inside
he's right it's magic so admire
[Applause]
[Music]
that was so hot the new mutants
rated bg-13 and on july 23rd don't miss
the new mutants panel at comic-con at
home
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my marvel new mutants
comic-con trailer video in
x-men easter eggs if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we'll do a new amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with the new mutants characters in the
mcu
after the events of this movie there's
been a lot of talk of sequels so i'll
explain what's going on because the way
this movie came together
and the way they're releasing it later
this year that's right we might actually
get a chance to see this movie after the
many many different release dates
even though you probably noticed that
there is no actual release date
during the trailer that they just
dropped they added a bunch of new scenes
a bunch of ileana being a total badass
with her powers a bunch of the limbo
dimension
and some of the other villains so if
you're not sure who the actual villains
of this trailer are
because there's a lot of different
characters that they wind up fighting
during this footage
for the most part the main villain of
the movie is demon bear
he's basically the supernatural entity
that consumes the souls and magic
essence of
other people the director of the movie
referred to the film as being like a
rubber room horror film which is where
the
participants the people in the movie
don't realize what's real and what's
fake
so it's kind of implied that if demon
bear is going to be the main villain
he's using this
sort of weird reality alternate space to
trick them so that he can slowly consume
their souls
this is where iliana and the limbo
dimension are really important really
big x-men comic book easter eggs so if
you didn't know iliana rasputin aka
magic
is actually the younger sister of
colossus mainstream x-men team member
also big character during the deadpool
movies so because this is coming from
the fox marvel universe
you could think of her as the younger
sister of this version of colossus from
the deadpool movies but because marvel
has all those characters back it's sort
of up to them how they want to connect
this to the mcu later on if they bring
these characters back in a new project
oh i said no touching we know they're
doing deadpool 3 so it's actually pretty
easy for them to do that in the future
if anna taylor joy wants to come back as
magic inside the mcu
which sounds like she does the other
villains that you see her slicing up
with her magic blade are called the
smiley men
they're not necessarily big comic book
characters but it just seems like
they're other apparitions that are being
controlled by demon bear to manipulate
them to do what he wants them to do
when celia reyes is talking about how
this place turns your worst fears
against you makes you fight them that
also might be demon bear manipulating
danny moonstar's powers
turning them against her which isn't
quite what it sounds like she can
actually create
illusions based on people's nightmares
and use them against them
so that might be a little what's going
on here but because we're talking about
multiverse multiple dimensions
places like limbo it's sort of like them
turning fake things
into reality you get a little bit more
of cannonball's powers that's charlie
heaton from stranger things you probably
recognize him immediately
there's a bunch more scenes with roberto
decosta using his sunspot powers it
actually looks like they polished the
special effects for his character too
this is a little bit more comic book
accurate he acts as sort of like a solar
battery he can absorb
solar radiation and give it off as
plasma energy
when he's doing that his body just looks
black like this
you all know about ileana rasputin she's
probably one of the most badass
characters that they have during this
that's why she's in so much of the
trailers just going crazy on everyone
then you all know maisie williams who's
playing wolfsbane pretty
self-explanatory power she turns into a
giant werewolf make all the direwolf
game of thrones jokes that you want
coming from game of thrones the deep
connection that the starks have with
their direwolves
now she actually literally turns into a
wolf during a marvel movie
the director also confirmed my theory
about some of the alternate post-credit
scenes and deleted scenes that they had
filmed previously
so when the whole fox disney deal was
going down and they were actually still
making the movie originally they were
going to have a big mr sinister post
credit scene it was going to be jon hamm
believe it or not and it was actually
going to be connected to that mr
sinister post-credit scene from x-men
apocalypse
which was also connected to the gambit
movie that channing tatum was going to
make once upon a time
remember when gambit was going to get
his own solo movie after that they
changed the new mutant's post credit
scene and it wound up being more of a
hellfire club scene
so antonio baranderis came in and filmed
some scenes the director confirmed that
he was going to play roberto decosta's
father who's going to be a member of the
hellfire club and the hellfire club was
going to become the main villains of the
new mutants trilogy that he had planned
there were going to be sequels to this
movie
he did say he was hoping that marvel
would still allow him to make them
because they have so many big x-men
characters that are going to be around
during marvel phase 5.
it'd also be really easy to do those
stories as a disney plus series like new
mutants as a disney plus series
right now based on marvel's timeline and
when they're introducing big x-men
characters in marvel phase 5
it doesn't sound like they're actually
going to start doing big x-men disney
plus series until they do them in a
movie
and that's not going to be till at least
2023 to 2025
but we do have a bunch of big x-men
stuff coming up later this year
especially in the one division series
so the one division x-men stuff that
they're introducing is just really
through the multiverse alternate
realities and sort of folding in
some of the x-men characters obviously
some of the other x-men characters will
debut in different ways
but as a lot of you guessed doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness the
multiverse itself is a really easy way
to integrate
other x-men characters they're getting
really twisty with the way they're doing
it in the one division series with
scarlet witch though because it involves
her children from the comics and i've
already done a couple videos on the
backstory behind her twins in the comics
and how the mcu is sort of changing a
couple things to do them during the one
division series and how they might be
integrated into future
young avengers projects because her
twins eventually do grow up to become
young avengers
but the other big x-men mcu talk that's
been happening recently aside from
people just getting really excited about
wolverine and new versions of the
characters
is black panther ii just because so much
stuff is going on with mutants so just
think about it as a broader idea
we already know about the name or easter
egg from avengers end game and from nick
fury's map
way back in iron man 2. i just did a
video recently about janelle monae who
said that she actually had a meeting
with marvel and ryan coogler about black
panther 2 and about playing the storm
character during that
so it does sound like regardless of who
shows up during that movie
marvel is seriously thinking about doing
mainstream x-men characters around black
panther 2.
you've probably heard the russos talking
about x-men in the past year since
avengers end game came out people
wanting them to know if they'd ever come
back to direct another marvel movie my
prized possessions is uh
incredible hulk 181 it's the
introduction of wolverine
uh and uh you know i think he'd be an
amazing character
to introduce into this uh this world
um you know the x-men the burn run from
from the 90s was a big book for me they
implied
they would come back to do some
wolverine or an x-men movie at some
point
then hopefully they'll stick around for
avengers versus x-men down the road i'm
totally happy with them coming back as
much as they want but they have so many
other films that they're working on
right now and marvel is gonna do that
rebooted x-men movie for at least a
couple more years
short term the mcu fantastic four reboot
movie has a little bit of priority over
that but that as well is also still a
few years away so it's going to be a
while before we see those characters
black panther 2 is just the first mcu
movie that people are pointing to
as having the first legit big x-men
character show up
let me know in the comments though who
you want to play some of those big new
x-men characters like who do you want to
play storm in the mcu and where do you
want to see her show up first
last big thing is what's going on with
disney plus and then releasing some of
these movies video on demand
will marvel just keep delaying their
movies or will they just drop them
on disney plus video on demand
originally new mutants was supposed to
come out in august but right now
in major cities they've actually had to
re-close theaters so it's possible at
this big comic con panel that they're
doing for new mutants
next week that they could announce that
they're releasing the movie video on
demand
i think everyone's just getting really
tired of waiting and they just want to
see some brand new content like just
give us something new
we've been watching all the old stuff
over and over again don't worry whatever
they end up releasing in terms of
trailers next week at comic con
of course i'll do a video for it there
will be big marvel stuff happening
separate from comic-con later this year
too while you wait for everything click
here for my brand new spider-man 3
tom holland video and click here for my
brand new venom 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]